bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
à 20 jours taux quotidien de mortalité
le plus élevé au monde en suède 25 morts
par jour par million d'habitants certes
ce sont des chiffres qui me faut
remettre dans leur contexte pour autant
ça reste un taux dramatique bien plus
élevé qu'en norvège au danemark ou en
finlande
effectivement oui cessé ces derniers
jours ce sont des donc des chiffres qui
ont été pris sur ces quelques derniers
jours qui montrent donc que le nombre de
morts par capita donc c'est le nombre de
morts par jour par million d'habitants
est un des plus élevés en europe
maintenant comme disait ma concitoyennes
avant j'écoutais le live
je pense qu'il faut aussi réfléchir sur
le long terme
d'un point de vue l'humilité de masse
les sens de la stratégie suédoise c'est
d'empêcher la surcharge des hôpitaux
avec un flot constant de patients mais
sans gros pic qui ferait qu'on serait
incapable de prendre en charge tous ces
patients
et il faut aussi prendre en compte
l'aspect économique une crise économique
grave peut-être associé avec une romande
but de morbidité
donc voilà est ce que vous comprenez que
certaines voix s'élèvent pour dénoncer
les choix un peu trop souple du
gouvernement suédois
un gouvernement qui t as qui était
rebours des autres alors au début on
attendait de voir les résultats et là
malheureusement les chiffres sont là
quand même
je suis d'accord et je comprends tout à
fait qu'une partie des collègues
s'insurger et aussi que le reste des
pays d'europe pointe du doigt la suède
mais encore une fois je le répète je
pense que ce sont des chiffres qui sont
pris sporadiquement sur quelques jours
aujourd'hui c'est le cri sanitaire du
corona elle dure depuis plus de 6 mois
elle risque de durer encore plus d'un an
on parle d'un vaccin à la fin 2021 voire
donc il faut aussi penser à une
stratégie qui sera durable
et ça c'est une question que moi même je
me pose est ce que c'est mieux d'avoir
une population qui confinait parakou
puis avec de nouvelles vagues avec un
nom potentiellement élevé de cas qui
risque de surcharger les hôpitaux ou
est-ce que c'est mieux d'avoir une
population moins confiné mais plus
prudente sur le long terme
est ce que en fait la norvège a misé
sur ce qu'on appelle l'immunité
collective la suède oui l'assiette
pardon alors je pense pas que je pense
pas que l'essence dans la stratégie et
l'immunité de masse je pense que tout
est plutôt centré sur le fait d'empêcher
la surcharge des hôpitaux etc ça qu'ils
veulent qu'ils veulent essayer de faire
de contrôler le flot de patients et
c'est quelque chose qui pour l'instant
fonctionne moi je peux vous dire que je
travaille dans le sud de la suède à lund
on travaille dans de très bonnes
conditions
nous avons l'équipement nécessaire pour
être protégé
le personnel soignant et tester de
manière régulière et immédiatement au
moindre symptôme et le flot de patients
n'a pas forcément changé depuis le début
de l'épidémie on travaille encore dans
de bonnes conditions
vous êtes en première ligne dans un
hôpital en sus est d'ailleurs bon ça
veut dire que vous ne dénoncez pas les
mêmes problèmes qu'il ya en france un
manque de matériel personnel est prouvée
manque de moyens alors ce que je peux
vous dire hélas et c'est avec mon
expérience locale donc dans l'hôpital où
je travaille parce que je peux pas je
peux pas parler au niveau général de
toute la suède notamment à stockholm il
ya une densité plus plus importante de
personnes n'est probablement peut-être
plus de problème pour le personnel
soignant en tout cas ici je peux vous
dire que le personnel travaille encore
avec le sourire qu'on a été bien
préparée à cette épidémie qu'on nous
annonce et une vague de kaki qui allait
arriver et on s'est préparés mais pour
l'instant elle n'est pas vraiment arrivé
et tout est sous contrôle
alors ensuite à dun 90 % des morts ont
plus de 70 ans
certains disent même que la suède est un
peu en train de risquer la vie des
personnes âgées
est-ce que c'est également ce qui est
dit chez vous c'est seulement ce qui a
raconté dans les médias étrangers
alors je pense qu'il ya une différence
entre ce qui est dit dans les médias
étrangers et les médias locaux
pour répondre à cette question je pense
que ça serait mieux de le contacter
notre épidémie épidémiologue nationale
ndf technique parce que je n'ai pas
toutes les statistiques et je préfère
pas me prononcer sur les statistiques au
niveau national parce que je me base
seulement sur l'expérience que j'ai ici
à l'hôpital
une grande partie des patients qui sont
dans nos services et je parle des
service infectieux je suis pas en
comment dire dans les soins intensifs
sont effectivement plus des personnes
des personnes âgées de plus de 65 ans
qui sont donc un groupe à risque merci
beaucoup
mille se faire notre homme d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
externe en médecine en suède et que vous
étiez en direct avec nos enfants